today on the matt welsh show many
parents are finally calling for greater
transparency in the classroom
and more control over what sorts of
things their children are taught if
that's the goal and it should be then
why aren't there cameras in every
classroom in the country documenting
everything that teachers do and say to
their students
uh we'll talk about that today also five
headlines including the media marks the
six-month anniversary of january 6th as
we get further and further away from
that event their retelling of it
gets more and more dramatic and absurd
andrew cuomo also declares gun violence
a public health emergency and joe biden
wants to go door to door to get people
vaccinated that's not creepy at all in
our daily cancellation we'll discuss the
orgy of ungrateful
whining and complaining that accompanied
july 4th this year all of that and much
more today on the matt wall show
[Music]
you know if you're someone of an
advanced age like myself
at 35 um or if you're you know if you're
if you're older than like my kids then
you probably have many memories from
your childhood that are documented
on antiquated technology camcorder tapes
physical pictures um those sorts of
things and the problem is
that those kinds of uh memories the
memories fade and the things that you're
storing them on also can be destroyed
and lost
and left in boxes and all kinds of
things that's why you've got to rescue
them and bring them into the 21st
century and legacy box can help you do
that legacy box is an effortless way
to have your outdated media preserved in
a modern format and right now they're
offering 40 off so you can ensure your
memories are safe
for generations legacy box is a way for
you to easily and affordably digitally
preserve your past
process is so easy from start to finish
you pack and send the stuff
um their team digitizes everything by
hand and then they send it back to you
and you have it and
that's it i said it was easy and it
really is you can send your precious
recorded moments to a company that you
can trust legacy box is the world's
largest digitizer of home
movies and photos and has helped more
than a million families preserve their
past so
right now legacy box is offering 40 off
so your family can celebrate meaningful
moments as
at a fraction of the normal price visit
legacy box dot com walsh to get started
today that's legacybox.com
for 40 off legacybox.comwalsh
uh welcome again to the show before we
get started just want to remind you that
you know the best thing that you can do
today
to help me and really to help yourself
is if you're watching this on youtube
remember to hit like
and subscribe and if you're listening on
apple podcast remember to uh
to subscribe but also to leave a five
star review if you like the show and
even if you don't like it
still leave the five star review because
it makes me feel good about myself but
more importantly
it helps the algorithms and all that
kind of stuff and that is again it's the
most important thing you could do today
the other most important thing is you
can listen to what we're going to talk
about to start the show
um you know if you want to take a trip
let's say
and you can't bring your precious poodle
along for the journey you can always
hand them over to your local
dog boarding facility here in nashville
for example one fine option is a place
called
camp bow wow and if you go to camp bow
wow unpaid endorsement here you'll find
a feature
on the website that has become nearly
ubiquitous at these sorts of places
a live webcam and through this function
a customer is able to tune in anytime
and see how their pooch is being treated
and and cared for by the staff
they also might just be curious to know
what little fido or whatever is up to
and how he's getting along with all the
other hairy mangy
slobbering beasts there are many
potential reasons why a dog owner might
want to have
this kind of access and it's hard to
imagine any real
downside to it what's the we can imagine
some advantages to having
the webcam what's the disadvantage
everyone agrees that there is probably
too much surveillance going on in our
society today
but most of the bad sort of surveillance
is the kind
where we are being watched often without
our knowledge by people who have no
right or reason to be watching us
most of us agree though that
surveillance can be good and has a place
when it enables us to see what's
happening with and to
something we care about like our dogs or
our money
which is why nobody complains about bank
tellers being closely monitored
bank tellers today have cameras all over
the place focused on every little thing
they're doing
does anyone have a problem with that day
cares human daycares i mean also have
cameras for this same reason oftentimes
it's not that we actively distrust the
staff at the dog boarding place or the
bank or the daycare if we actively
distrusted them we wouldn't be sending
our dog there or
our money there or our kid there um
it's just that these people are handling
very precious cargo
and transparency and accountability are
therefore urgently important
you would certainly be quite suspicious
of a dog boarder who steadfastly refused
to put up cameras i mean it's one thing
if they couldn't afford it but
if they could afford it and said no we
we absolutely refused to do that on
principle
you probably wouldn't send your dog
there or daycare facility
you know imagine a daycare facility that
said that it wanted uh yeah we don't
want cameras because we want our staff
to have more privacy
as they care for your toddler you don't
need to see what's happening here you
can trust
us nothing would make you distrust them
more
than hearing that this is all to say
nothing of body cameras on police
officers most people these days
support the practice of body cameras and
are quite wary of any cop who doesn't
wear
wear one and the cameras in this case
work both ways it's why most people
support it
they create greater accountability for
police officers which is good because
they are
agents of the state who necessarily
wield unique power and authority so you
need to have accountability
but they also potentially protect cops
from any false claims made against them
just think about
where the cop in the mikaya bryant
shooting would be today if he hadn't
been wearing his body camera
remember witnesses in media reports
claimed that a racist cop
had randomly murdered a helpless unarmed
child it was only because of his camera
that we quickly discovered the truth
which is the unarmed child was a
teenager armed with a knife
and was in the process of trying to stab
another teenager to death when the
officer fired
saving the victim's life this is why
though police shootings themselves are
often controversial
the body cameras allowing us to see
these incidents
generally are not anymore in the
aftermath of any shooting caught on
camera
you rarely hear anyone cop or citizen
say that they wish we were not able to
see it
now you hear the opposite something
happens and and there's no body camera
and we all say well i wish we could just
see this
but nobody ever says after something
like bakaya brian is caught on camera no
one ever says oh man i wish there was no
video of this
so this all raises a question if almost
everyone agrees
that we should have cameras to see what
dog boarders
and bank tellers and cops and daycare
workers are doing
why don't we have cameras to see what
public school teachers are doing
if you would not send your dog
away for a few hours or a few days
without the ability to check in and see
for yourself what's happening with him
why shouldn't you have the same sort of
access to your own child
if you want this level of accountability
and transparency for people who watch
our pets
and handle our money and care for our
toddlers and enforce our laws
why shouldn't we want it why don't we
want it for the people teaching our kids
the current and uh of course
well-warranted backlash against critical
race theory in schools
represents i think something of an
awakening for many parents they finally
seem to realize
that the school system cannot be
implicitly and absolutely trusted to
teach children whatever it sees fit to
teach them
parents have a right to know what is
being taught and to have a say in what
is being taught
these are your kids after all despite
the ridiculous arguments put forth by
many on the left
and some especially feeble and useless
members of the right
teachers don't have a free speech right
to say whatever they want to the to the
children in their classrooms
there's no free speech here public
school teachers are government employees
entrusted to perform
a particular task they do not have the
right
to deviate from that task whenever and
however they like
they don't have the right to stand on
their perch as teachers
and assume the additional roles of
counselor psychiatrist parent
spiritual guru
their job is is important but it's
limited
and parents ought to know whether and
how that job is being performed
cameras are not the only way to
accomplish this task but they are an
important tool
and um and though we use them to this
end in so many other facets of life
we seem to have exempted public schools
entirely and that simply makes no sense
now when i went on twitter last night to
advocate for cameras in the classroom
i was met with intense pushback from
many people including many parents
who apparently don't want to know
exactly what government employees are
saying to their kids
which i find very strange and one common
refrain
was that cameras would infringe on
privacy
and and freedom in the classroom now i
understand the privacy objection
as it pertains to the kids as a parent
no i don't send my kids to public school
at all uh but if i did
i certainly wouldn't want a live
classroom webcam that any person could
use to monitor my children
you know i don't want random joe schmoe
down the street who doesn't even have
kids in the classroom
watching the uh the the classroom webcam
for whatever his reasons might be they
can't be good
um so that's a that's an objection
but there are easy and obvious ways
around this problem
the cameras could be password protected
only parents with custody of their
children are given
the code to access the cameras also the
cameras here's a really easy thing
could just focus on the front of the
room capturing just the teacher
perhaps only the audio would be
accessible to parents under normal
circumstances with the video being
released
whenever there's an incident or a
controversy like we do with police body
cameras
there's also face blurring technology
that can be utilized to protect the
privacy of children even more
there are dozens of workarounds which
immediately present themselves
if the concern is over the privacy of
the students in the class
that's a that's a reasonable concern but
we can deal with that we can get around
that
the thing is though for most critics of
the camera and the classroom idea
the concern seems to be equally if not
primarily
the privacy and freedom of the teachers
and i have no workarounds for that
because public school teachers
in their capacity as public school
teachers
should have no privacy
or i will say only as much privacy as we
grant
bank tellers and for the same reason now
we're not
we're not going to follow them into the
bathroom or even the break room
with cameras but when they're on the
clock performing the task for which they
are paid
they should be monitored closely if our
money is too important to simply
trust that the nice lady at pnc will be
honest in her handling of it
then how much more important are our
children
of course the main thing we're looking
to guard against is the psychological
abuse and exploitation of students
through ideological and political
indoctrination
which is an epidemic and it's going on
in every single school
in the country and that's one of the
primary
things that the camera could guard
against that's not the only thing
i mean keep in mind that according to
the department of education's own study
in 2004
this again i emphasize the department of
education
commissioned this study in 2004 and they
found that nearly 10
of students are victims of sexual
misconduct by educators
10 now that amounts to like three or
four million victims at any given time
all the more reason for greater
surveillance
and like police body cameras the
protection goes both ways
teachers who are falsely accused of
inappropriate actions in the classroom
which happens can simply point to the
tape
teachers stuck in parent-teacher
conferences trying to convince oblivious
parents that their little angel
is actually a demon-possessed terrorist
in the classroom
will now have video evidence to prove it
oh my my little junior would never act
like that oh he wouldn't
well here you go hit play
the advantages to cameras in the
classroom can be enjoyed by all honest
parties
that seems obvious to me so in the end
it boils down to this question i think
and you just have to think about this
is there anything that could happen in a
classroom
that you absolutely would not want
documented
on film
whatever that thing is it shouldn't be
happening in the classroom
in the first place and that's the point
and that's why we need the canvas now
let's get to our five headlines
if you're a a real american a
red-blooded american hopefully you were
doing some grilling over the weekend
on a charcoal grill which is the only
kind that i think is morally acceptable
um and uh and if you were doing that
then hopefully you had
moic which delivers grass-fed and
grass-finished beef and lamb pastured
pork and chicken
and wild caught alaskan salmon directly
to your door helping family farms become
financially independent outside of big
agriculture
and if you didn't have now you know
about them and now you can get them
their animals are raised outdoors their
fish swim wild in the ocean
and moink meat is free of antibiotics
hormones sugar all the other junk that
you get in prepackaged stuff
um you can sign up at mointbox.com walsh
to get a year of bacon
for free and then pick what meats you
want delivered with your first box
i'll say it again a year of bacon for
free what else i got to tell you
you can change what you get each month
and cancel anytime so it's very easy
very affordable you're getting great
product you can join the moic movement
today go to moicbox.com
walsh right now and listeners to the
show get free bacon for a year
that's one year of the best bacon you'll
ever taste but for a limited time
spelled m o i n k box dot com slash
walsh that's monkbox.com
walsh all right uh so i'm back from
from my second vacation going on another
one in two days no
that's it i'm i'm here i'm never gonna
leave again
day in and day out you will never be rid
of me ever again
two things uh two quick notes from not
really from
the trip well i had another long
marathon drive of a thousand miles that
i did
uh over the course of the last two days
and um
two two just things that i saw that i
have to mention to you because
to me they were notable um the first and
the main thing is i guess
a shout out i want to give to the town
of i think it was woodstock virginia
right off of um right off of of
of 81 and i was going through this town
and i saw and i hadn't i have it's been
years since i've seen this
i saw a radio shack
a real live radio show not a not a
museum it was like a real one
with with people inside it and uh it was
right next to
i kid you not a video rental
store in woodstock if you don't believe
me you can go
i'll send tourists now to woodstock it's
it's worth it just to see this
it's like i went through some sort of
time warp i don't know what happened
maybe maybe i hit 88 miles an hour what
what is it back to the future is it 88
miles an hour or you go to
i don't know but um and it was just
amazing to me and both these places seem
to be in business
and you kids you don't know about the
video rental places that was it was a
thing for a long time
so you're spoiled these days like you
don't understand the concept of of
if you want to watch a movie now right
or a show and uh
and netflix has it then you just go on
netflix on your computer and you watch
it and that's it
that's all you got to do but it used to
be that blockbuster or the video rental
place the local video rental place
they they could have there's a movie out
and blockbuster has it but then you go
there and they don't have it in stock
because other people have rented it so
there's a limited supply
it doesn't exist on netflix you don't go
to netflix and uh well
50 people have already write to this
movie so you got to wait
that was the thing you go into
blockbuster and you want to watch
aceventura pet detective
and 10 other people got there first and
now you can't watch that and then all
hell breaks loose because now you're
with your
friends or your siblings wandering
around the aisles debating what else
you're going to get
and a lot of times what they would have
is is i don't know who came up with
these movies but there would be a
knock-off version
instead of asentor pet detective there
would be like bob
the dog finder or something and you
could just go with that the knock-off
version which was never as good
so i saw that and that was a lot of fun
um and then the second thing that i saw
we have the picture here
which was not as fun a rest stop this
was a rest stop also off of 81
right as you get into tennessee at their
tennessee welcome center
and i get out of my car and there is
this
i don't know what it's some sort of i i
hesitate to call this
some sort of artwork that had been put
right outside of the tennessee welcome
the first thing you see welcome into the
state and it's this
thing here so the state of tennessee
had a spot available at their welcome
center they said we need some artwork to
put here
and they and they went with this it's
just this
this mangled mess of random shapes cut
out of sheet metal
what is it looks like some kind of i
don't know it's like
caribou or deer in some sort of
sexual embrace i'm not sure what it is
you know 100 years ago if you went to
that exact same spot
that would be a beautiful sculpture of
like some sort of historical figure
and now it's that
disgraceful um other than that it was a
fine trip
okay let's move on to uh speaking of
disgraceful
number one yesterday was the six-month
anniversary
of january 6th and the left in the media
they're really milking this thing
you know you're milking anything when
you're when you're when you're uh
acknowledging the month anniversaries
it's like you do with your first
girlfriend in seventh grade
today's our two and a half month
anniversary babe that kind of thing
um and they're doing that with january 6
now so now it's the sixth month every
month we have to mark it
and as we get further and further away
from this
the description of it becomes more
dramatic
to the point where now we have this is
matthew dowd he was on msnbc
former gop strategist which tells you
everything you need to know about the
gop
and here he is arguing shamelessly
and publicly that uh january 6 was was
not just
like 911 in fact it was worse than 9 11.
listen
well i absolutely agree with you joy
that i think it's much worse than it was
on january 6
it's much worse than it was in november
it's much worse after january 6 and part
of the problem is is because
because there's been no accountability
it's given permission
to do more of this and not only is it
giving permission to
just average people out there who might
do crazy things
it's allowed the republicans just to
continue this big lie that they've
pushed across i was yesterday i was in
kentucky
i decided to go to lincoln's birthplace
and his boyhood home
and i was reflecting about it because
one of the things lincoln said was
america will never be destroyed from
outside
america will destroy itself and i think
that's what i fear about right now and
one of the things if you think about
this
what would happen if after 9 11 we had
done nothing
we had done nothing think about that we
had done nothing after 9 11.
and to me though there was less loss of
life on january 6
january 6 was worse than 9 11 because
it's continued
to rip our country apart and give
permission for people
to pursue autocratic means and so i
think we're at a much worse place
than we've been and as i've said i think
to you before i think we're in the most
perilous point
in time since 1861 in the advent of the
civil war
worse than 9 not even as
bad as but worse than 911. uh
he he acknowledges though yeah there was
there was less
loss of life there's less
yeah that's one way of putting it in
that there were three
thousand people killed on 911
across uh three states
and uh and there's so three thousand
um versus
none except for the
only the only person killed by
riot-related violence was ashley babbitt
who was killed by
we think a capital police officer that
we've never been told who it is
but uh the only reason i say none is
that matthew matthew dowd
and the media they don't count her they
themselves have decided that she doesn't
count
so as far as they're concerned none
because they don't acknowledge that
um but really there was one how
how many people did the rioters kill
zero zero
zero people killed three thousand
zero so it is
technically correct uh in inaccurate to
say there was less loss of life
but uh to call that an understatement
would be itself a
an enormous understatement but this is
this is what they're doing you know it's
it's
they they all you need is for the
the narrative to metastasize which
happens very quickly
i mean within hours
on january 6 they had settled on this
thing of a
it was an insurrection and it was a
deadly insurrection
and five people were killed or seven
people were killed the number kind of
fluctuated whatever it was
deadly insurrection and then very
quickly after that
the facts come out and it turns out well
no it wasn't a deadly insurrection at
all
except for the uh the rioter that was
killed
in fact it wasn't an insurrection at all
much less deadly
but it doesn't matter it does not matter
all they need is the story and then they
can run with the story forever
it's a reason why they still say hands
up don't shoot
um but as dramatic as that was
it pales in comparison to this andy kim
who's a congressman from new jersey
of course uh he tweeted this
and there's a picture of him holding his
cheap blue suit and he says
six months ago today i wore this blue
suit as i cleaned the capital after the
insurrection
now i just donated it to the smithsonian
january 6 must never be forgotten while
some try to erase history i will fight
to tell
uh tell the story so it never happens
again here is one story
and then and this is a whole this is a
whole thread now it says
story of the blue suit um
he says when the smithsonian asked me to
donate the blue suit i thought about how
the suit itself is unremarkable
bought off the rack at j.crew during a
holiday sale i wanted a bright blue new
suit to wear to biden's inauguration
then january 6th happened could we just
stop here for a minute you're going to
an inauguration this is a big thing for
you
obviously it's a big deal um you're uh
you're a
you're a congressman you're a state
you're a representative
of the country can you go and get a
tailored suit
i know you can afford it you're running
into j
crew off the rack and buying a suit
that's embarrassing enough on its own
um and then he continues then january
6th happened
i woke with the news of the winds in
georgia i decided to wear the blue suit
i bought it to be a suit of celebration
and i thought what better way to give
the suit meaning than to wear it
when i confirmed the electoral college
and then later to the inauguration a
suit of celebration that you spent
72 dollars on in clearance come on
um and then he goes on i can't even read
this whole thing while he goes on for a
while
talking about how he wore the blue suit
and then there was the quote-unquote
insurrection
and then um he helped to clean up a
little bit he picked up some old uh
just some some like plastic bottles and
stuff that had been left there
and he put those in a garbage bag and it
was this heroic moment
of uh by andy kim and now he's giving
his suit to this mission he's giving it
to a museum
and i'm i'm a big fan of smithsonian i'm
a big fan of museums
just think about how confused future
generations are going to be
when they go to the smithsonian and they
see all of this remarkable
you know these remarkable historical
artifacts
and then they just see someone's cheap
suit from j crew hanging there
you would almost think like did someone
take this off and leave it here by
accident what is
this even an exhibit what is this
oh no this is the suit he was wearing
when some people trespassed in a
building that he was in
i got to tell you i was in uh you know i
was once
in a building um where there was
trespassing that happened a few years
ago
and in fact i was i was at an applebee's
speaking of high class
i was at applebee's and i don't know
what exactly happened but some so
someone came in
and they weren't supposed to be there i
don't know what exactly but they got
kicked out maybe they were drunk or
something
and um and i'll never forget that moment
i'll never forget that day
i'll never forget the trauma that i
experienced from that
and so now i'm thinking that i'll take
the the flannel and the genes that i was
wearing that day and i'm gonna donate
in fact i'll donate the flannel to the
smithsonian
um my my pants i'll send on a rocket
ship to the moon
to have place there in memoriam
my shoes all burn and i'll scatter the
ashes across the sea
so that nobody ever forgets the day
that someone got kicked out of an
applebee's while i was sitting there
i almost died
theoretically
a lot a lot of heroism in the world
today let's go number two here from
nbc new york says governor andrew cuomo
has issued the
first in the nation executive order
declaring gun violence in new york as a
disaster emergency
the first step in a comprehensive plan
that aids that aims to
tackle the surge in gun violence
throughout the state
the announcement was made at john jay
college of criminal justice in manhattan
in new york tuesday afternoon
this is the first step in a
comprehensive plan cuomo outlined
composed of seven key areas all with the
aim of quelling the gun violence surge
the key areas are quote treat gun
violence like the emergency public
health it is
um target hot spots with data and
science
what does that mean this is how we're
gonna solve gun violence target it with
science
what are you gonna do about gun violence
uh science
what do you mean that you know science
solves everything positive engagement
for at-risk youth
number four break the cycle of
escalating violence
number five get illegal guns off the
street number six keep guns out of the
hands of dangerous people seven rebuild
the
police community relationship just a
whole bunch of broad
vague you might as well say um i have
one step to solving the gun violence
problem number one solve the gun
violence problem
how do you put break the cycle of
escalating violence as one of the steps
on the way to achieve
that is the goal now how are you going
to do that
is the question oh you're just going to
you're going to declare
gun violence a public health emergency
okay that's really going to help
this this is part of the the religion of
the left they believe that
every bad thing is a public health
emergency
because everything has to be framed in a
sort of sanitized
medical kind of way everything becomes a
health crisis it's a
it's really a medical scientific issue
and why do they do that because they're
trying to remove the moral dimension
from all of these things
and they think just by declaring
something a public health crisis that
that
in itself will solve the problem and
in trying to remove the moral dimension
what they're looking to avoid is the
reality
that gun violence happens just like all
other kinds of violence
and there's a lot of it happening in our
cities and not all of it involving guns
but
it happens because individual human
beings
make the choice to behave this way
but they don't want to talk about choice
because when you talk about choice then
you have to ask well
why are they making this choice why are
they acting this way
if you got a 17 year old guy out there
on the street in
in in new york or chicago or baltimore
and he just goes up
and shoots someone dead to steal his
shoes
or because he's selling crack on the on
on a street corner where where he would
prefer to be um yeah you could blame the
gun if you want and say this is a public
health emergency
or you can ask what in the world has
happened
that would that would lead to this 17
year old
throwing someone's life away and his own
life away
for nothing this is someone who does not
value life his own or anyone else's
how do we get there that's the real
disaster emergency and i'll tell you one
of the ways that we've gotten there
you wanna you wanna talk about the real
disaster emergency quote unquote in
urban communities in the cities it's
that almost
all of the people responsible for this
quote unquote gun violence
don't have fathers in the home that's
not the only thing that's not the only
contributing factor but it's a big one
you know when you've got 70 80 percent
of fathers
choosing not to be in the home raising
their own kids
yeah you're going to have a gun violence
epidemic and you're going to have a drug
abuse epidemic and you're going to have
a
suicide epidemic and you have you have
crime of all kind is going to be an
epidemic
if you were to cut that if even let's
say we're at 70 in the city right now
if we were to make it 45
or let's say 40 cut it down by 30
percent
40 would still be an enormous number
but you would see magically so much of
this gun violence would disappear
but we can't discuss that that is not in
the seven um key areas that he outlines
doesn't talk about that doesn't talk
about how almost
all of these perpetrators of gun
violence
don't have dads
um governor cuomo also on the the gun
violence front tweeted this as well he
said the gun industry is the only
industry in america with immunity from
civil lawsuits
it's an insult to victims of gun
violence today i'm signing legislation
to
reinstate public nuisance liability for
gun manufacturers in new york state
um i thank the sponsors of the bill well
that's just that's just a lie just so
you know when you hear this thing about
how gun manufacturers are
uh are not liable or they're they're
insulated from from
from lawsuits or anything they have
immunity from civil lawsuits
that is not true a gun manufacturer can
be sued
under the same for the same reason that
the manufacturer of any other product
can be sued
if you sell someone a product and it
malfunctions it does
something that it's not supposed to do
and somebody gets hurt or killed in the
process
you get sued for that if i take my glock
19 down to the range and i pull the
trigger and it explodes and kills me
my family could definitely sue them for
that
but what you can't do is sue
someone or sue the manufacturer of a
product
if somebody else takes that product and
uses it
in in in an illegitimate and illegal
criminal way
that's what you can't sue gun
manufacturers for obviously
if there's an ax murderer running around
out there you can't sue
home depot because that's where he
bought the ax much less can you sue
the company that made the axe
you can't do that if somebody buys the
axe and they pick it up to uh cut some
wood and the
you know the blade comes flinging off of
the axe and hits someone in the head and
kills them again you could sue them for
that
but if you take the axe and choose to
use it
in a way that you're not supposed to um
then you're the one liable same for guns
so this is a misnomer this is a
falsehood it's a lie in other words
okay next year joe biden unveiled his
plan for getting the holdouts who are
not vaccinated vaccinated and he said he
wants to go door to door
and find all you people and drag you
there by the scruff of your neck here he
is explaining
because here's the deal we are
continuing to wind down the mass
vaccination sites that did so much in
the spring
to rapidly vaccinate those eager to get
their first shot
and their second shot for that matter if
they needed a second
now we need to go to community by
community neighborhood by neighborhood
and off times door to door literally
knocking on doors
to get help to the remaining people
protected from the virus
right uh that's not creepy at all
you know i talked about there's there's
good surveillance and bad surveillance
good surveillance is when it's uh is the
citizens we the people who are given
the ability to to see what uh
you know government workers are doing
especially with respect to our children
so that's good surveillance
um bad surveillance is something like
this
first of all we should have we're
supposed to have privacy we're supposed
to have medical
privacy our medical records are supposed
to be private
so joe biden and his administration
shouldn't even know
who hasn't gotten vaccinated and who has
that is private medical information so
if the government is
accessing that information and then
going to your door and knocking on your
door and saying you need to get
vaccinated
that's a form of surveillance and that's
a bad kind that is big brother
i had a lot of people by the way going
back to that i i just uh
as i said when i put this out on twitter
yesterday about about cameras in the
classroom and uh
a lot of people very upset at this idea
and that's one thing that i heard is
this this is orwellian this is big
brother
a lot of people is orwellian is that's a
term used by people who've never read
orwell
probably don't even know that his name
is george orwell i don't even know where
the word comes from
no this this is when citizens
are surveilling the state that is the
opposite of orwellian is
literally the exact opposite of
orwellian
this is more along the lines of
orwellian
and it's all it's all completely
pointless and useless because
just so you know um the people at this
point who are not vaccinated
it's not because they don't realize the
vaccinations are out there
it's not because they don't know how to
get vaccinated
it's not because they no one is giving
them the information about the
advantages of
vaccination that's not the reason they
know
that it's there they know they could get
it they know that it's free
they know that it's really easy to get
they know that it would take 15 minutes
just go down to cvs and they could get
it done they know all of that
but they're not getting it anyway why
for their own it's their business for
their own reason
they don't want to they don't feel like
it they're worried about side effects
they're worried about long-term whatever
whatever their reason is
they have a reason and there's nothing
you could say to them at this point
that's going to change their mind
unless you really start putting on the
pressure
you know unless you start issuing
threats in that kind of thing
which which maybe is what happens next
because it doesn't really clarify
what exactly will be said uh when they
knock on the door but i guess we'll find
out
one other thing from the white house
this is white house spokeswoman jen
pasake
speaking out about systemic racism in
education yesterday let's listen
nicole hannah jones who passed up a
position at unc
will be teaching delaware at howard um
she said this morning that it took
protest
the threat of legal action all this just
to get to a 9-4 vote
what does biden make of the unc process
and her decision
and is this an example of the systemic
racism that he promised to heal
well i have not spoken with the
president about the decision on tenure
by
by the institution in north carolina i
will say that the students at howard are
quite lucky to have her as a professor
and in their
in their family uh but i think there's
no question that
um there is continues to be systemic
racism in our country
we see that in a range of sectors
including in some learning institutions
uh but
uh the president that's why the
president is continuing to make racial
equity and addressing racist real equity
is a central
priority and crisis that he would like
to address and focus on as president
this is a great story by the way i don't
know if you heard about this nicole
hannah jones she's the
you know the race hustling hack um
16 19 project and all that but she was
um
not offered tenure originally by unc
and uh she said this is racism
and all of that she threatened to sue
and then finally
they said okay we'll give you tenure and
she said you know what i don't want her
anymore and she declined it
after insisting for so long that it was
racism
i want it you didn't give it to me okay
here you go i don't want it
just like a child this is what my kids
do this all the time
they're fighting over a toy i wanted he
took it i want the toy okay here you can
have the toy i don't want the toy
anymore
so nicole hannah jones did that uh which
is which is
embarrassing unc which i which i think
is fantastic they deserve to be
embarrassed
um and uh jen passaki's
response to that is that there's this is
somehow systemic racism and there's
still systemic racism in the education
system
which of course we have to say again
she's right there is systemic racism in
the education system um
and it's systemic racism that leads to a
situation where
you know a white student
who is more qualified than a black
student might not make it in
and instead the black student will be in
there um
because of racial discrimination against
the white person so there is systemic
racism in education but it is anti-white
and also anti-asian racism
but we always have to clarify that
because you hear conservatives sometimes
say oh systemic racism and education
that doesn't exist
and i probably say that sometimes when
you know when you get a little
uh when you're not being specific enough
no it does exist it's just that it's
anti-white
all right finally here's an inspiring
message i just wanted to share with you
if you're looking to be inspired this is
from diddy
um sean combs puff daddy and this got
some attention it's an instagram post
and there's a video we'll play the video
first
uh but it's really the caption that
matters here but first here's the um
here's the video
[Music]
too with the ocean as your backyard all
i right want it i want it bad you hear
me
and i'm gonna allow myself to not have
mango
i hustle hard you know what i mean i
don't know
my way no
[Music]
okay so he's clearly high as a kite i
have no idea what he just said there's
something about mango and
you work hard so you can have your own
mango i guess i think it's like it's a
very mango-centric
inspirational message which really
i think you could just go to like whole
foods or something and get a mango
really you don't have to be rich to do
that but um
i don't know if he thinks that you have
to fly down to a tropical location to
get a mango because you really get him
at the grocery store but
anyway here's the caption is what got my
attention he says
one day when i was growing up i woke up
and there was 15 roaches on my face
at that moment i said hell no i refuse
to live like this work hard believe in
your crazy dreams
and never settle hashtag love
i'm just 15 roaches
on your face so many questions like
first how does a roach infestation get
so bad
that you have 15 of them on your face
what is this fear factor were you
sleeping on the set of i mean
how did all of those get on your face
and what were they doing there
did you smear bacon grease on your face
before you went to bed
i don't and and and here's the but
here's even more
more pressing question how did you know
that it was 15 it's such a specific
number
did you count them what kind of person
wakes up and goes oh no there's roaches
on my face
one two three four five
it doesn't make sense to me i i'm
calling shenanigans on this on this
roach story
maybe there was one roach on his face
and
the story has grown into 15.
in five years he'll be telling the story
and there was there was six thousand
roaches crawling all over his body who
knows
i'm not sure if i believe it okay moving
on to reading the youtube comments we
gotta go back uh
fall we gotta reach back far in time
almost as far back as when radio shack
existed except in woodstock virginia to
find these comments
on the last show we did on thursday but
here they are
diana says america is so great a country
even those who hate it
won't leave and we have we have more on
that in the daily cancellation in just a
second but i
i agree with you another comment says it
used to be about letting adults do adult
things
but now it's pushing adult things on to
children
yeah that that is true that's there's a
lot of that that happens and um
the last show we did was about the
washington post
editorial from a woman who brought her
young children to a gay pride parade so
they could watch
kink so they could be exposed to uh the
the the fetishism and kink of of gay men
um so in a way that is children being
exposed to adult things but i got to
tell you
the other the other problem i have is is
how this word adult
is now used because we think
oh um these were these were men
in leather thongs being let around on
dog leashes
and well that's adult that's that's for
adults
or when you're driving down the highway
and you see adult superstore
and this is so so adult has become
shorthand for perverse weird bizarre
disgusting stupid
that's what adult has come to mean now i
agree it's adult in the sense that
kids should not be exposed to this
absolutely
but i just i lament the fact that the
word adult has come in
when you see adult superstore or
whatever
that should mean that you go in there
and there's like
russian novels and comfortable leather
chairs
and you know fancy globes for your
office like that's what we should mean
when we talk about
it should mean sophisticated mature
um or even mature doesn't work anymore
because that word also but sophisticated
that's what it should mean
intelligent
um but by the just so you know don't if
you do
don't you go to the adult store you're
not gonna find russian novels um
at least not the kind that you hopefully
would be looking for
matt bertrand says just saying it would
probably suck to play scrabble against
walsh
i don't know exactly what you mean about
that by that if you mean that i'm
a master at scrabble then you're right
if you mean that i'm i would just be a
really annoying person to play
board games against because i'm way too
competitive
and i get really angry when i lose you'd
also be right
um and finally mrs mack says matt you
flew on an
airplane i thought you cancelled and
banned flying
um i i did cancel and ban it but uh
you know i also canceled and banned
birthdays and i still celebrate on my
own
because i it's i think it should be
clear by now and i haven't
denied this that the cancellations i
have my own set of rules
um and there's the rules for you and
everybody else
and there's rules for me so i did fly i
flew again
last week oh that was one that reminds
me one other thing that happened
i thought was funny um this was last
week i was in the nashville airport
and this is nev i never had experienced
this before i was sitting in the
terminal
waiting for my flight and this blaring
alarm comes on it's like a
foghorn type alarm and then there's a
recording that says um
there's a fire emergency please evacuate
the building immediately
and the report the recording keeps
playing and the alarm is is blaring and
it's really creepy
and then i look around and i don't know
if i should be
encouraged by this or not but nobody
moves we all just keep sitting there
while this alarm is saying
everyone evacuate immediately we all sit
there no one leaves
so the good thing is there was no panic
this was not a panicky bunch
but also we weren't reacting at all i
know my reason was i was thinking well
if there's really a fire i'd probably
see smoke this could be a false alarm
and i don't really want to leave the
airport because then i got to go through
security again i got to be on my flight
in 30 minutes just seems like a big
hassle
so i'll take my chances here and then
they came on
uh two two three minutes later and said
that it was a false alarm and so we were
fine but i just
i just thought that was great how we all
completely ignored the alarm
um and it worked out it was a gamble but
it paid off sometimes that happens
i am so relieved to be home finally for
good
never to leave again because when i'm
home that means i get access to all of
my
my pillow products uh our bedroom which
is which is
which is adorned with all my pillow
stuff my pillow has a passion to help
everyone get the best sleep of your life
my pillow didn't stop by simply creating
the best pillow which they did
my pillow created the new giza dream bed
sheets they look and feel great which
means an even better night's sleep for
me which is crucial
for a busy schedule my pillow found the
world's best
cotton called giza it's ultra soft and
breathable but
extremely durable and my pillow sheets
come with a 60 day money back guarantee
and a 10 year warranty
the first night you sleep on the giza
sheets you will never want to sleep on
anything else
giza dream sheets come in a variety of
sizes and colors my pillow's making a
special offer also for my listeners
you'll receive
two for one low price plus free shipping
you've got to take advantage of this now
so go to mypillow.com click on the radio
listener square and use promo code
dailywire
then you'll find not only this amazing
offer but also deep discounts on
all my pillow products including the my
pillow mattress topper my pillow towel
sets
and so much more call 1-800-951-7163 use
promo code dailywire
or go to mypillow.com make sure you use
promo code dailywire
mypillow.com and
you know once upon a time bravery was
defined by a man's fearlessness in the
face of danger today it's defined by
many as rejecting gender stereotypes and
wearing a dress that's what we consider
a brave man these days which i'd argue
isn't brave at all
that means it's time for a hefty dose of
true heroism so
americans can remember what what they
enjoy
uh why they enjoy such unparalleled
levels of freedom today
that's why in honor of the um of the
week of america's independence the daily
wire is celebrating real bravery with
our newest podcast america's forgotten
heroes
the podcast boasts seven episodes
detailing the lives of seven legendary
men
who risked it all for america one of
those men was frank luke an ace pilot
with a tendency to fly alone and disobey
orders
who shot his way into history after
taking down 17 enemy aircrafts over the
course of 12
furious days and these weren't just any
aircraft they were observation
balloons which were by far the most
heavily defended air targets of the war
luke's final flight took place when he
was only 21 years old
shot fatally by german troops after
shooting down three more
enemy balloons so this is a man who fit
more into 21 years of life than most of
us will fit into 90 or more years of
life
um and you want to hear all about this
story and so many others so subscribe
now to america's forgotten heroes on
apple podcast spotify
or anywhere you might listen because the
last episode is out today for a total of
seven episodes again america's forgotten
heroes subscribe today
and now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
you know i spent this july 4th at a lake
house drinking beer
eating copious amounts of meat watching
unsanctioned and arguably unsafe
fireworks displays put on by
different houses around the lake at one
point someone's firework misfired
and a ball of flame descended gracefully
from the sky
and landed directly on the roof of the
house next door
unfortunately it was slightly raining at
this point so no fires were started
though the guy who owned the house
was not amused for some reason my point
is simply that
i just like so many of you celebrated
the holiday the way that it was meant to
be celebrated patriotically and joyfully
and gluttonously and gratuitously and
stupidly
but july 4th for many other americans is
not a time for something so frivolous as
happiness
it is rather a time for anger and sorrow
these are the americans who profess to
hate this country though they
choose to still live here gorging
themselves on the bounty of western
civilization while bitterly complaining
about the people
who provided that bounty to them most of
these ungrateful whiny losers can't even
really explain
why they hate this country so much as
this recent video from
campus reform uh demonstrates
are you proud to be an american no
i feel embarrassed to be an american
every day um
not really in this climate no like i'm a
black person
so obviously i experience a lot of
uh you know there's like oppression that
comes with that
um not most of the time
i think sometimes it's just a little
embarrassing you know
be proud of what and what is there to be
proud about if you're black and being
like you know because it's just like
it's a
still a lot of stuff that goes on for
black people i think that's a
complicated question for me i think i
i i think most of the time no
at least over like the past four years
um it's been tricky to
you know love to be an american well
like america sucks you know because like
it oppresses black people or whatever
how does it oppress them what is the
exact nature of this oppression
that's never explained the people who
hate america are like sullen teenagers
who go around complaining that their
lives are so difficult
and miserable even as they enjoy the
easiest and most painless existence
that the world can possibly offer to a
human being in fact those same sullen
teenagers crying that they're being
oppressed by their parents
because they aren't allowed to stay out
until 1am on a school night or whatever
it is
often grow up and turn into the sorts of
adults who cry that they're being
oppressed by society or systemic racism
or the patriarchy
for reasons that are even more
superfluous july 4th has now become an
occasion
for such people to air their grievances
and while this is annoying and pathetic
it's also illuminating
because in airing their grievances
you're able to see just how stupid
are those grievances and how
hypocritical and also stupid
are the ones airing them so here's one
representative example that is worth i
think some special attention
this comes from a twitter account called
lakotaman
um his bio tells us that he has a ba in
sociology
you perhaps can already guess where this
is headed simply based on the fact that
this is the kind of guy
who brags about having a bachelor's
degree in sociology
on july 4th lakotaman ba tweeted this he
says
hey america fu for desecrating our
sacred mountain
hashtag happy fourth and it's
accompanied by a picture of presumably
himself and two other people pointing
their middle fingers
at mount rushmore now many questions
potentially arise questions like what
sort of person drives all the way out to
mount rushmore just to flip off a bunch
of rocks
i guess it kind of reminds me of the
time when i drove four hours to the
beach
in order to scream at a mound of sand
it's really annoying when sand gets in
your shoes
and i just thought it was time that
someone finally sent the message
but in any case more to the point let's
consider the specific complaint that
lakota man ba has here
he says that america has desecrated his
sacred mountain the black hills
by carving uh the mount rushmore
sculpture into it
he also says in subsequent tweets that
this was
land theft and colonization etc
now this claim of land theft made by
modern native americans
is almost always species and
hypocritical but when it's made by
someone descended from the lakota tribe
about the black hills
the irony is even more pronounced lakota
man b.a says that his
people owned the black hills it was
sacred to them
the white man ruthlessly stole and
desecrated the land that belonged to
them
but does that mean that the lakota were
the first to inhabit this region of the
country
no far from it before the lakota the
black holes were
occupied by the arapaho in fact the
chain of possession during recorded
history goes back to the 16th century
and during that time the land was
claimed by the arapaho kiowa crow
cheyenne
and arikara tribes before we got to the
um
to the lakota and that's only recorded
history
archaeologists tell us that the very
very first occupants of this region
were called the clovis people about 13
000 years ago
well archaeologists did tell us that now
we're told that the clovis people
came somewhat more recently and they're
predated by another group of people who
we know very little about
the point is that the black hills his
sacred mountains
are not his at all his people were not
the first to occupy it not the second
not the third not the fourth not the
fifth not the sixth
indeed the lakota came in the 19th
century moved everyone else out took
over and immediately declared the
mountains sacred to them
like they just got there killed a bunch
of people and said these mountains are
sacred
keep something in mind here when we say
that one tribe
moved other tribes out of the region
we don't mean that they asked them to
politely to leave
okay they didn't show up with a with a
with a note and say well
would you hey guys would you mind
skedaddling here
would you would you mind moving over and
giving up some space would you mind
that's not how it worked in indian
culture war
over land was very common
and it was very very brutal
slaughter decapitation dismemberment
rape enslavement scalping
were all common features of these
conflicts speaking of scalping
the earliest the earliest evidence that
we have of this practice to my knowledge
dates to the 14th century in south
dakota
a mass grave from that period has been
uncovered and we don't know exactly what
happened
but whatever happened it's been dubbed
the crow creek massacre because the
human
remains show that hundreds of people
were cut to pieces scalped tortured
mutilated
and this is before any white man had set
foot on that part of the globe
way before which means that um that that
one native american tribe
did that to another and there's nothing
especially surprising about that that's
how they treated each other
and that's what they did when they
wanted to take the land occupied by some
other group
now bringing this back to the black
hills one indian tribe conquered and
massacred another tribe for access to
that land and then that tribe was
conquered and massacred by another and
so on and so until finally
not but a century or so before the white
man showed up the lakota came and did
the same
stealing the land from the thieves that
had most recently stealing stolen it
before them
then a short time later in the grand
scheme of things the us government rolls
in and a series of battles are fought
over those mountains called the black
hills war
and the u.s won the battle that is
the u.s conquered the people who had
most recently
conquered the land we're left then with
the with the original question
who owns that land
if you say that conquest is illegitimate
and it's always wrong to conquer land
and overthrow the people occupying it
then you can't say the the lakota own it
because they did the same
and you can't say that the cheyenne own
it or the acaira or the
kiowa so who owns it
who's the victim of this theft the
clovis people
with their stone tools 13 000 years ago
maybe we should find some of them and
apologize
but they weren't there first either they
somehow came to supplant some other
stone age people before them and i can
pretty much guarantee you
that that supplanting was not peaceful
very few things were at that point in
our history
this is the absurd rabbit hole that you
fall down whenever you try to claim that
the u.s
stole the land it currently occupies in
order for a thing to be stolen it must
first be owned
but if you say that the most recent
indian tribe who lived on it owned it
then you're legitimizing conquest and if
you legitimize conquest
then there's no reason why the united
states conquest
should not be considered legitimate
as i've argued many times conquest was
the way of the world all over the world
everywhere among all people for
thousands of years
if you wanted it you took it
if you wanted to keep it you defended it
if you couldn't defend it you lost it
if you couldn't take it you didn't get
it as simple as that
america didn't invent this concept we
didn't even practice the most brutal
form of it not even close
today we're simply blamed because we
were better at it
americans played the exact same game the
indians played
they observed the exact same rule of
conquest a brutal rule but a universal
one
and they were just better at it they won
and now we're supposed to be ashamed of
that victory and weep over it and
apologize
centuries later but apologize to who
the conquerors who were conquered the
thieves who had their stolen goods
stolen
that's absurd i for one apologize for
nothing
and i'm ashamed of nothing and i'm happy
that america is here
and i'm happy that it won that conflict
and that war
i'm happy that this civilization is here
i would rather live in this civilization
and i think everyone would including the
lakota man b.a
but anyone who is ashamed of america is
free to leave
and on the way out please just know that
you are of course
canceled and we'll leave it there for
today thanks for watching thanks for
listening have a great day
god bless america and godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky
the show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by nikka geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters
the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021.
today on the ben shapiro show andrew
cuomo declares a disaster emergency on
gun violence
our most powerful institutions have been
hijacked by radicals and our education
system is now rife with critical theory
of all sorts that's today on the bench
bureau show give it a listen